es steht für feuer das goethe- und lucas
cruz steht für unfair und fragen steht
für nukleare waffen tragen habt ihr
jetzt kennt dieses nukleares
waffenarsenal verstanden echt nich haare
leute hier ist wieder eure mal wanne und
willkommen zu einem neuen video was sich
exakt so anfühlt wie das letzte content
der spaß macht und ihr will die konsum
und material wurde dann ist das einzige
was meinem leben noch einen sinn gibt
ich habe gerade den ersten teil
hochgeladen ich hab natürlich auf eure
meinung gewartet denn ohne eure meinung
bin ich nicht meine haare sind dunkler
geworden aber ja sind auf jeden fall
dunkler geworden mir gefällt dieser
untere teil noch nicht gern und ich habe
natürlich wieder so in 3 stufen programm
in meinen haaren und zwar ist das jetzt
hier so hey dann wird es hier immer
dunkler und dann wird es hier wieder
hell und das zieht natürlich auch nichts
draußen dann sind wir mal ehrlich ich
muss ich auch sagen ich habe so viele
graue haare im 3 es ist ja nicht schlimm
graue haare kriegt man halt wenn man
älter wird aber die dann wirklich so zu
sehen weil er keine haarfarbe mehr drauf
ist das letzte mal habe ich von der
woche entfärbt aber ich würde halt echt
gerne sehen was passiert wenn ich da
noch mal wirklich den rest raus ziehen
weil auf jeden fall noch ganz viel drin
steckt that's what she said und dieses
mal vergesse ich kein ethisches vorher
nachher
[Musik]
naja
und das brauchen wir natürlich wieder
zum haare entfernen
kala b 4 weil ihr so oft geschrieben
habt das ist carla bork heißt seit heute
die ganze zeit kala b 4 muss sagen es
ist wieder wie ein überraschungsei ich
freue mich auf das ergebnis
das einzige was mir wieder im weg steht
ist dieser unglaublich stinkende stinkt
ein pups mülltonnen geruch der gleich
hier wieder im raum ist hier lesen sie
würden auch ein café ein eigener service
für mich selbst ist echt scheiße was
habe ich keine haare mehr oder
ich finde meine haarbürste nicht und
deswegen wird es für den händen so haare
sind jetzt durchgekämpft kommission alle
profis hier an dieser stelle wie
entfernen
die gp ist so wie man dieser tage wie es
erleben willkommen in vanessas drogen
labor
[Musik]
eine stinkbombe aktiviert und jetzt
müssen wir wieder 60 sekunden schütteln
so leute wie ken und anders schönes
denken
seid ihr bereit für den ersten job keine
gute idee eine gute idee freunde keine
gute idee
[Musik]
bolt ich versuche gerade umgekehrte
psychologie für mich selbst ist der wenn
ich meinem gehirn sage das ist gut
riecht denke dass es gut
das riecht wie ein sommertag in berlin
wenn man gerade an der mülltonne vorbei
läuft merkt dass da irgendjemand von
eierschalen und liebe diesen beruf
das machen sie so lange bis ihr ganzer
hsv
wir sollten auch anfangen ihren
bildungsauftrag zu erfüllen könnt ihr
mal in die kommentare schreiben
wenn das so mit dem haare färben
angefangen hat also wann hat sich der
erste mensch gedacht ich bin mit blonden
haaren auf die welt gekommen
aber ich hätte gerne rot ist ja was ich
meine
dazu gehört ja viel uns ist das heute
komplett normal haare werden klar macht
jeder aber wann war dieser moment wann
kam so dieser ersten strophe buchdruck
maschine wurde gerade erfunden und alle
so yeah jetzt müssen wir nicht mehr
alles abschreiben hammer und dann stand
dann eben jemand gute idee aber ich
hätte gerne eine andere haarfarbe und
alle so was möchtest du bist du kaputt
in den kopf
was wäre so die nächste erfindungen gibt
es irgendwelche erfindungen der letzten
zehn jahre die so einschneidend sind wie
haare vermutet maschinen ich habe
zurzeit ein
großes geheimnis von dem ich euch jetzt
gerne berichten würde schon wieder
komplett timo golz durch angst ich hab
das auch mein tattoo bekommen aber
tattoo farbpigmente sind sie nicht
zusammen oder ich weiß nicht ob das so
eine gute idee war aber ich habe jetzt
nur eine packung verwendet und weil ich
aus polen kommen mag ich gerne geld
sparen
jetzt packen wir uns ein schock wieder
in frischhaltefolie nicht richtig gut
und sollte definitiven neuer trend
werden
[Musik]
ein dieses mal mit dem geruch aber echt
gut ausgeblendet mir fällt der jetzt
erst wieder auf und die stink scheiße
wird jetzt zugemacht
[Musik]
den kann
damit die wärme sich auch richtig gut
entfalten kann schließen wir uns jetzt
einer gang an ohio leute wir sehen uns
in 60 minuten nicht jetzt noch ein paar
leute in meiner zelle verprügeln
[Musik]
jetzt müssen wir das spiel ist bravo
recht
[Musik]
apa
ich liebe rausspielt ist versteht sich
von selbst dass niemand seinen hut für
ein paar kröten in seiner leder
bauchtasche wieder raus kühlen haare
riechen wieder wie scheiße um mein gott
es sieht so aus als ob ich nackt wären
aber versprochen ich habe ein handtuch
an respekt ja okay ich habe mich
angezogen und dann wollte ich nur ganz
kurz in folge immer ganz schauen
und dann habe ich es wieder übertrieben
ist hier fielen
[Applaus]
wien
hey i can't stop me kirche st ok girls
wird halten wir von diesem leute ich bin
ganz froh dass dieses zweite mal jetzt
rausgeholt habe weil jetzt ist der
übergang mit schöner aber können wir mal
über dieses ständige haarfarben wechseln
spricht ich hatte jetzt ja ziemlich
lange sehr dunkle haare und ich dachte
auch die ganze zeit dass es mir am
besten stehen und fand es auch die ganze
zeit super habe ich hab so menzel sagt
und ich muss was anderes haben egal wie
gut ich dass da vorfahren es muss sich
sofort ändern ich weiß nämlich das video
problem nicht alleine bin da gibt es
ganz viele unter euch die das genauso
haben und ich will einfach wissen was
ist der psychologische hintergrund waren
möchte man das dann plötzlich und jetzt
gehe ich mein kind wieder von der schule
abholen denn ich bin eine american marc
hoffmann sind unterschiebt ihr denken
nicht so ok warum teil 2 es ist nichts
passiert rocker jetzt einfach meine
grauen haaren werdet zu vanessa die
weiße ich hoffe euch das video gefallen
und wenn ja dann zeigst mir auf jeden
fall mit dem daumen nach oben folgt mir
gerne auf instagram tik tok twitter
tweets und ich wünsche euch einen
schönen tag abonniert gerne mein arzt
mehrkanal lauschas mr
falls das noch nicht getan habe dort
wird es bald sicher auch regelmäßiger
videos geben irgendwann kriege ich
nämlich mein leben wieder auf die reihe
gut leute bis dahin physik aus gier und
macht rhein und bis bald und ich möchte
ganz doll lieb